[Music]
so let's talk about something that is a
staple of Doctor Who and in my personal
pain has been one of the things that has
just kind of been there without a lot of
purpose for a frightening amount of time
when I actually stopped and thought
about it let's talk about the Daleks
what's been going on with them and maybe
what should be done with them or
shouldn't be done with them in the
future I'm actually now quite hopeful
for the Daleks because I'm hoping that
Chris Chibnall is gonna come in and
really want to put his stamp on them do
his Dalek story because if we're being
completely honest I don't feel like we
have had a proper Dalek story since
victory of the Daleks and I say that
knowing fully well that they've appeared
plenty of times since then but that
episode really did feel like that was
Steven Moffat attempting to do his stamp
on the Daleks and I know he didn't write
it but it was in his era it was the
attempt during his era in his time as
the showrunner to really be like this is
us and our version of the Daleks cuz
Davey's definitely had that during his
era and you know very firmly you know
put his stamp on what his take on the
Daleks was and you know we get victory
of the dogs we get a nod to some earlier
stuff we get the new paradigm Daleks
which the fandom soundly rejected so
hard that we basically only ever saw the
supreme the white supreme Dalek show up
a couple more times after that and then
kind of never talked about it again and
I have to wonder if that kind of took
the wind out of the sails for interest
from Moffat and his team of regular
writers to try and do a full-on proper
Dalek story again because I guess I
the family just went well we tried it
didn't work people didn't like it now
let's move on and I know that Daleks
have shown up since that episode but
really think about their appearances
since then we had a couple in the
Pandorica opens and BIGBANG but it's not
about them they're just on hand asylum
of the Daleks you might be thinking but
it's not about the Daleks it's about Amy
and Rory's relationship and it's about
this this early protolith cara it could
have been done with Cybermen the story
doesn't structurally fundamentally
change that's also the case with into
the Dalek and even though it seems like
let's really zoom in on Daleks like it's
not really about them and what they're
up to
they've got their appearances in day of
the doctor in time of the doctor but I
mean they're just kind of there because
these were big seminal episodes or they
were supposed to be and you just you
kind of have to have them there again
not about them or what they're up to
even the Magician's apprentice in the
which is familiar isn't really a Dalek
story it's a Davros story which isn't
quite the same thing and like I said we
haven't really had a truly proper Dalek
focused story where here's what the
Daleks are up to here's their latest
scheme here's their latest plan here's
what the doctor has to stop we haven't
had one of those in a long long time and
we're well overdue for it so I'm really
hoping that Chris Chibnall will come
we'll come to play we'll come with
ambitious ideas to move things forward
not like an examination of Daleks like
into the Dalek was and into the dogs
fine not another look at Davros not not
any more of these oh just stick them in
somewhere to fulfill our obligation
because and the details of this are
sketchy but to the best of my knowledge
it seems to be fairly accurate that
doctor who has to have Daleks appear
every single series in some capacity
that's part of the deal they have with
the Terry nation the state as to the
rights to be able to use the Daleks so
we're gonna get them every year no
matter what which is a shame because
honestly they should have been put on
ice for a couple of years because having
them show up in these
Kamio things these are men or these
stories that aren't really about them
they're just at the villain you know the
monster the threat that is inserted into
a story that's about something else have
really started to devalue the Daleks as
a whole and that's a shame now obviously
part of that is the fact that we do have
to see them every year even if there
isn't a notable story for them to appear
in but it doesn't help but like I said
it seems like Moffat and his team gave
up trying to do notable stories with
them after fandom rejected victory of
the Daleks and the new paradigm Daleks
as harshly as they did
since then everything every time the
dogs have shown up like I said they're
window-dressing it's it just it isn't
about them certainly not in the way that
something like stolen planet and
journey's end or bad wolf and parting of
ways or doomsday or even Nevel examine
end and evolution of the Daleks those
were about the Daleks those were about
what they were doing we haven't had that
in a long time and to be fair like you
know Davey's really pushing and here's
the Daleks new big plan and having them
be defeated every time was also
devaluing them in a different way so you
know I do appreciate to a certain extent
sort of downgrading them to more just
have them up here status for a little
while but it's been too long at this
point in dummy victory the dots was
series 5 we have had 5 completed series
since then where we haven't had a again
in my estimation a true proper Dalek
story so Chibnall
if you're watching this and I know you
are yeah I'm on to you make a bold
statement make a definitive statement
about what you're doing with Daleks
about the direction that they're going
what is it gonna be I have no idea not
my business to tell you but there's
plenty of ways to go there's plenty of
things to do we haven't seen the Daleks
tried to truly enact a proper plan to do
much of anything in a real long time
just start there
start basic I mean bring back the melons
if you're desperate maybe you can find a
way to make those things actually work
honestly I would say bring back the idea
of the schisms between Daleks the
infighting that we saw in things like
remembrance of the Daleks revelation of
the Daleks that really played up that
yeah they all kind of have a similar way
of thinking but they're not always on
the same page and some of them want
things that others don't or some of them
want to go about it in ways that others
don't that's something that the modern
era has touched on occasionally but
usually only on a one-on-one basis with
Dalek Caan and the one from into the
Dalek and things like that we haven't
had that real proper schism like how
cool would it be to have a story be
about a Dalek Civil War where the reason
the doctor has to come in and stop it is
because it is being waged in a way that
it's caught that is causing so much
collateral damage because obviously
Daleks don't care what they wipe out if
they're trying to you know if there's
some kind of power struggle going on
between two different factions imagine
the damage that they could do to a
planet to a solar system to a galaxy if
they're just tearing through trying to
get at this other faction of Daleks
let's bring that back let's do something
with that and that will add that because
that would give us something big
something proper something about the
Daleks themselves but would also avoid
what was starting to happen with Davies
witches they have a plan it fails they
have a plan a fails they have a plan of
fails this can be just about focusing on
the destruction of them filtered through
a notion of just them you know hurling
the worst that they've got at each other
but and just and just what gets caught
in the crossfire of that that could be a
way to really up again and kind of on a
bigger scale thing do what Dalek did in
series 1 which is to re-emphasize how
dangerous these things are and to make
them imposing again because they've kind
of become window dressing at this point
now you don't have to go with that idea
that's just the one that off the top of
my head then I think that would have a
lot of potential but I'm also not a
professional writer I mean if you want
to hire me I'll take the job but I'd
like to think that Chibnall you your
team you are smarter than me you're
cleverer than me I certainly hope you
are so you can probably come up with
better ideas but please give us
something big with the Daleks cuz I just
feel like we haven't gotten it for a
long time and they deserve it so that's
kind of my thoughts on the current state
of where we are with the Daleks in
Doctor Who and where I think we should
be going from here what are your
thoughts on all this whatever they are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it do all the stuff why
couldn't I be a t-shirt support me on
patreon whatever you want to do links
for all that stuff and more is down in
the description so until next time this
council is adjourned so until next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]